Boris Johnson's decision to suspend
Parliament hasn't just drawn criticism
from his own backbenchers as we were
just hearing but from members of the
public to this week protesters descended
on Westminster many claiming that mr.
Johnson is acting like a dictator the
government though says what they're
doing is completely within the rules and
we're joined now by a member of the
cabinet the International Development
Secretary Alok Sharma very good to see
you look the part of the problem here
surely is that we're being told this
propagation is happening to set out a
domestic agenda to sort out the Queen's
speech we know that's not the case don't
we well Stephen I think there's a lot of
froth and actually if I may say so
certain amount of manufactured anger
around this issue I mean let's just look
objectively at what is happening here
this parliamentary session has been
running for a long time in fact it's the
longest parliamentary session for almost
400 years and the idea that we have a
Queen's Speech we have a new session
that is a perfectly normal routine thing
happens normally once a year as I said
this session has been running for a long
period of time and this is about setting
out a exciting agenda that the
Conservative Party in the Prime Minister
has we've already made it clear that we
want to make sure that we leave European
Union brexit happens by the 31st of
October and no ifs no buts but then
actually across the country what people
want is for us to focus on the domestic
agenda the Prime Minister's shown an
enormous amount of energy since he's
come into place and he's already set out
what people wanted to see which is more
money for the NHS in terms of frontline
more money for schools and more money
for policing but that is our agenda and
that is what resonates with people on
the doorstep while that may very well be
true the defense secretary Ben Wallace
it was as you know caught on camera
making comments which were effectively
saying yeah we've got the domestic
agenda but actually the timing of this
and the length of this propagation is
about getting through brexit well as I
said if you if you have a look at this
as perfectly normal and actually for the
past 80 years Parliament has always not
sat during a large part of September and
the early part of October because we
have a conference season and
before the summer recess there was no
discussion from from any of the parties
that somehow this shouldn't happen this
is just a recent issue that seems to
have come up and if you look at the
number of sitting days where Parliament
not be sitting as a result of us going
forward for this new session the Queen's
speech it's literally a handful of days
there is plenty of time when we go back
next week to have a discussion about
brexit there'll be plenty of time to
discuss per exit and our agenda either
side of the the European Union meeting
that takes place in the middle of
October so the idea that somehow we are
shutting down debate I think it's
completely wrong and yet if we look at
some details on the House of Commons
library it's got a list of how long
propagation has gone on for since 2010
on average eight days and now we're
looking at about 34 I mean people are
going to look at that suspiciously well
as I said the the idea that this is sort
of some type somehow unusual I think
it's completely unfair Parliament was
anyway not going to be sitting for a
large period of time and if you look at
the number of sitting days where it
won't be sitting where it might have
done is literally a handful so I think
there is a lot of froth around this the
key issue is there's plenty of time for
debate you've already heard from one of
my colleagues over you debate next week
on this that we debate when we return in
October but the key thing from the
government's perspective is that we will
be planning we will be leaving the
European Union on the 31st of October no
ifs no buts and then focusing on that
really important domestic agenda I just
say to Stephen yeah I knock on doors
like all my colleagues week after week
out there in in the doorsteps of of
certainly reading what people want to
see is for us to get brexit done to get
that out of the way and then to refocus
on the issues that matter to them on a
day to day basis and that is more police
more funding for schools more money for
the frontline the NHS and that is what
the Prime Minister's already set out and
we will see further announcements I'm
sure at the spending review on Wednesday
and yet all this whole argument around
brexit and the side that one was about
taking back control and about this huge
piece of democracy that we put in place
about getting back sovereignty for the
United Kingdom and the UK Parliament
this is removing so whether you you
think this is you know of
thirty-five days or whether it's just
four or five days in in real terms at
Parliament isn't going to be sitting the
reality is it is removing some of the
say that parliamentarians can have on
this issue how is that a democratic move
well I would disagree with that we've
had three years of discussion of our own
brexit there is time for more discussion
around brexit and also it's
fundamentally it's worth remembering
that the European Council will take
place in the middle of October so you
know we won't know whether there is a
deal we certainly want to deal that's
what the Prime Minister has set out very
clearly we want to have a deal but we
won't know that the details of that
until the 18th of October as I said
there's plenty time after that to debate
not just the domestic agenda but also
any future deal when it comes to brexit
you mentioned plenty of time before as
well these additional days that we've
got before me next week is going to be a
very busy week for you all if it does
get through the House of Commons that
you if they get a majority saying action
needs to be taken looking at potentially
extending article 50 will the Prime
Minister be compelled to do that well
look I mean I I campaigned to remain I
voted remain but I was very clear at the
time the referendum that I would respect
the outcome of that referendum and the
outcome was very clearly that we should
leave the European Union it was very
clear-cut Labour MPs consider of MPs we
all stood on manifestos in 2017 saying
that we will respect the referendum that
is what we now need to do and it's
interesting you've got john macdonald
coming on after this john macdonald
jeremy corbyn they all said at the time
that we should respect the referendum
otherwise there would be a lack of trust
in democratic processes and actually
that's what happened you know if you
look at what happened in the local
elections and the European elections
that was a reaction to the fact that the
two main parties did not follow through
on leaving the European Union when we
said we would but as I said there is a
possibility next week you may not have
the numbers and that there may be some
movement against the government position
here well and it may require the prime
minister to seek an extension will he do
it is he compelled to do it
well firstly we'll have to wait and see
I'm not going to prejudge what may or
may not happen next week the fundamental
point though is that for conservative
colleagues for labor colleagues and I
would say this too actually all
parliamentarians is that we must respect
the out of the referendum and also we
need to give the Primus too time to get
this new deal you know by all accounts
he had a really good g7 meeting he had
good interactions with some of you
counterparts we have made very clear
that in September we're happy to meet
twice a week between our two negotiating
teams have other discussions required
but we want to get a deal but there is a
fundamental point here which the Prime
Minister conveyed at the g7 as well some
of his counterparts which is that we
want any future agreement not to have
the backstop now you know I've read all
the stuff that's gone on today in the
papers nor the rest of it the reality is
that the previous withdrawal agreement
which contained the backstop did not
pass on three occasions didn't pass then
it won't pass again and in fact having
the backstop also potentially makes us
rule takers from the EU for forever that
is not what we want we want that out we
want a deal but we will be leaving on
the 31st of October no ifs no buts this
is where it gets complicated and where I
think people at home might start to tear
their hair out you say you want a deal
you want the backstop out that's
absolutely crucial to that deal Michel
Barnier
and indeed the rest of the EU
negotiating team on this say that is not
going to happen
absolutely not on the table why don't
you just therefore come out and say
actually we're just gunning for a no
deal now well we've said we want a deal
and actually you talk about the EU it
takes two to tango what we are doing
very clearly is setting out the case
that we won't have a deal we've set out
the parameters for that and we've said
we're prepared to have that discussion
and the Prime Minister had some good
discussions at the g7
but what we're also doing is preparing
for the eventualities off a No Deal
we've turbocharged the work that we're
doing there so we are ready and the best
way Steven the Prime Minister made this
very clear the best way of making sure
we get a deal is to demonstrate that we
are ready for No Deal
but again it's back to that point of I
mean do we believe what politicians are
saying and say we're really pushing for
a deal here but when we're told
categorically what you were asking for
will not happen
why can't politicians then turn around
and say well actually it's we know we're
not gonna get this so we're going for a
No Deal well there is a negotiation
which is ongoing we hope that we will
end up with a deal we've made it very
clear what we would like on this and
let's see where we get to but the
fundamental point is that we need to be
ready for no deal we are doing ab c--
that and we will be leaving on the 31st
of October and no ifs no buts and no one
should be in any doubt about that you
talk about frustration out there in the
country the frustration in the country
for very many people is that we have not
yet left that's what people voted for
there was a majority for us to leave the
European Union we have not delivered we
must do this by the 31st of October and
you talk about another extension the
reality is another extent you already
had - by the way Stephen they're not led
to anything another extension is not a
destination
what another extension is is another big
loss of trust in democratic processes
and that is actually something that we
as politicians collectively have to
avoid a lot of it hangs on the balance
of course as to what happens next week
what legislation is put forward whether
others apart from the government can
take control of the order papers if a
number of your colleagues the likes of
David Gork turn around and rebel should
they lose the whip well I've seen some
of this sort of stuff in the papers I'm
not going to preempt any discussions
that may or may not be taking place
around that but there is a fundamental
point here which is that we all stood on
manifestos saying that we would respect
the outcome of the referendum and we
need to honor that and what I would say
to my colleagues is that actually siding
with the likes of Jeremy Corbyn John
MacDonald they need to reflect very
clearly what these people want they do
not want a delay embrace so they want to
frustrate brexit and you've just heard
David cork talk about the fact that he
doesn't want to see Jeremy Corbyn
leading the country well you didn't need
to
be very clear whose side you're on are
you on the side of people who want to
frustrate brexit people who would
actually ruin the economy people who
frankly at the end of the day are not
prepared to stand up for Britain or do
you want to stand with the people
deliver on the referendum result well in
terms of the people it it ultimately
looks like it could be heading back
towards the people doesn't it I mean if
we end up with effectively a stalemate
in Parliament this coming week if you
say we are definitely leaving no ifs no
buts but Parliament frustrates that this
week which is a very real possibility
at what point then does the Prime
Minister turn around and say we've got
to have an election even if it's before
brexit we've got to have an election
well we had an election in 2015 we had a
referendum in 2016 we had another
election in 2017 what people actually in
this country want and what the Prime
Minister wants and what I want is for us
to deliver on brexit and then and then
get back to that domestic agenda which
is what constituents up and down the
country want to see and I can't tell you
what is going to happen next week I'm
new you heard my colleague David golf
not setting out what you know those who
who may try and do something will try
and do so I can't I can't really sort of
comment on that all I would say too is
it's very clear from the government's
perspective is that we will be leaving
on the 31st of October no ifs no buts
and actually from the government's point
of view the agenda for next week is very
clear the big issue is the discussion on
the spending review which the Chancellor
will pronounce on and that will set out
that domestic agenda going forward ahead
of a a Queen's speech and as I said the
promise is already being very clear more
money for the NHS more police officers
more money for schools that is what
constituents people in the country want
that is what this government is going to
be delivering Sharma appreciate your
time this morning thank you